[Música]
muchas gracias a todos a mí cualquier
acontecimiento que una una gente una
países me encanta esta es una de las
razones por los cuales me encuentro y
aquí tengo ya muchos años esto no lo ha
dicho el caballero cosa que le agradezco
nací exactamente en la mitad del siglo
pasado y bueno pues sí he vivido
bastante y afortunadamente he vivido
bastante y puedo para contarlo entre
otras la presencia entre nosotros cada
año de estas aves maravillosas de estas
aves de paso que son los cormoranes su
nombre científico phalacrocorax carbó es
decir cuervo calvo lo cual suena así
como amerindio que diría alguien
políticamente correcto nosotros iremos
películas de indios y de vaqueros con
todo mi respeto absoluto hacia los
primeros pobladores que sepamos por
ejemplo de los eeuu de américa pero
quiero decir que este es el término
exactamente porque son córvidos
realmente estos cormoranes pero yo
quería comenzar con unos versos de
antonio machado
esos esos que dicen al olmo viejo herido
por el rayo y en su mitad podrido con
las lluvias de abril y el sol de mayo
algunas hojas verdes le han salido
porque me refiero un olmo porque lo
veréis después o quizás lo conozcáis ya
en el embalse de molino de la voz
embalse por cierto hoy absolutamente
impensable el año 69 así se hacían las
cosas se mutiló el río guadarrama con
una presa nada que ver con la presa del
gas co sobre el ilustrado después
nuestra ya amiga
eulalia una presa mucho más rústica que
al regresar perdón por el pleonasmo al
represar el río creo ese embalse bien
entonces había un olmo el horno lo
podemos ver todavía lo que ha quedado de
ese olmo y ahí año tras año se venían
pasando los cormoranes que yo sepa desde
el año 89 el año 89 que es la primera
vez que detecte su presencia o así lo
hice constar en mi diario
dietario o cuaderno de bitácora bien
desde el año 89 observé alborozado me
encantan las aves como estas aves cada
vez más verían posándose en ese olmo
hasta que haya mediados los años 90 una
tormenta echó abajo gran parte de ese
olmo todavía podéis ver la base del
susodicho bien entonces escribió una
carta al país mandé una carta al país
que publicaron en la cual lamentaba la
falta de posadero para estos cormoranes
inmediatamente en molino de la hoz
surgió un pequeño grupo tengo que decir
me apena decir lo que verán todos
prácticamente todos extranjeros sobre
todo un señor llamado norman marketing
de kenianos supremas y una señora
llamada diana esto ccoo fueron los que
comenzaron a crear la asociación de
amigos de los cormoranes hay un monolito
lo podéis ver en el molino de la hoz
según entramos a la derecha donde la
caseta de los guardias es un poco más
arriba que recuerda el hecho
de cómo se alzó ese árbol ahora hablaré
de un árbol de acero de acero cortén que
hizo un escultor húngaro llamado miklós
bánffy
a él lo debemos yo en realidad yo mandé
la carta al país me identifique con el
tema fui a la calle agustín de
betancourt pidiendo permiso a la
confederación hidrográfica del tajo para
poder limpiar ese estanque ese embalse
ese pantano permiso denegado por el
desastre ecológico que supondría
pensemos que el río guadarrama nace muy
bonito muy simpático en la fuenfría río
de arena quiere decir en árabe y es en
los que wat es el prefijo para el río en
árabe guadalquivir guadalix guadarrama
todos estos gitanos pero dijeron que de
ninguna manera entonces este río como
digo
bien por los molinos por villalba por
torrelodones cada vez más sucio hasta
desembocar en el tajo es afluente del
tajo no lejos de toledo en un lugar
significativamente llamado la gran
cloaca ni más ni menos entonces dijeron
que de ninguna manera que ocurre
entonces en ese estanque o embalse ahora
mismo que hay cuatro metros de agua
sucia puerca podéis comprobarlo al pasar
por ahí y cuatro metros de lodo
y supimos esto por aquellos hombres y
mujeres rana que colocaron colocaron lo
que sustituyó al primer proyecto que fue
una especie de balsa con bidones con
bidones debidamente ancladas porque se
estudió muy bien el tema por parte de
estos señores normal martín diana
etcétera y los cormoranes necesitan una
base al que no que no se mueva una base
que esté perfectamente fija para lo cual
había que anclar la os podéis imaginar
que ese árbol de acero está debidamente
sujeto debidamente anclado y además está
perfectamente integrado en la naturaleza
que esto es lo bonito si molino de la
hoz algunos de vosotros y residentes en
molino es un enclave privilegiado
desgraciadamente en parte gracias a ese
embalse vienen los cormoranes por otra
parte los cormoranes se alimentan de
esos peces contaminados ahí había carpas
había bogas había luz yo creo que
actualmente hay luces más bichos que hay
por ahí animales pues hay también unos
patos alguna hoja que algún vecino
benemérito ha depositado ahí que alegran
la vista
entramos y salimos todos los días de
molino de la hoz he visto alguna garceta
egretta garzetta que es el nombre
científico una garza pequeña perfectos
que nadan perfectamente bien como los
cormoranes en asia hay algún lugar que
el cormorán grande este el que tenemos
en molino esta variante el phalacrocorax
lo utilizan para pescar le ponen una
argolla el se sumerge es un
nadador espléndido y un piloto
espléndido también caminar llano
evidentemente y por cierto si os fijáis
cuando podéis por ahí veréis como
despliegan las alas para secarse no son
impermeables como lo son las alas de los
patos por ejemplo que sí son
impermeables como sabemos entonces qué
fauna billo al llegar a molinos llevo un
molino pues desde el curso 75 76 pero
empecé a venir a molino el año 74 ya
llovió desde entonces ya han pasado
muchísimas cosas que vi entonces en ese
embalse niños que se bañaban vi snipes
pedaletas también había cierta fauna que
hoy ya no existen conejos cierto que
aquellos con éstos
tocados por la misma ptosis ya sabéis
esa enfermedad que les ponen los ojos
tremendamente vidriosos y por allí se
veían se veían jabalí se siguen viendo
que existen es una especie endémica
precisamente abundan de hecho a veces en
exceso porque ahora con la civilización
entre comillas bajan a los contenedores
de la basura como pasa con las cigüeñas
por ejemplo las cigüeñas antes venían
por san blas la cigüeña verás y si no la
viera es año de nieves no hoy en día
tenemos cigüeña esto del año en alcalá
de henares por ejemplo porque porque
vienen a los vertederos con lo cual a
veces muchas aparecen muertas porque
tragan lo que no deben en los vertederos
ya su alimentación no es natural en las
rozas tuvimos una la recuerdo daba un
poquito de pena verla por eso en el
escudo de las rozas hay una cigüeña la
llamada cigüeña amarilla que algunos de
los presentes quizás recuerda la cigüeña
maría yo la recuerdo verdad por ahí por
las calles un decir de las rozas cuando
la roces era pueblo pueblo yo he visto
cómo evolucionó todo esto las rozas los
20.000 habitantes majadahonda cuando
viene a vivir en bajaron del año y 79
también 20.000 habitantes y hasta los 80
de hoy
y esto que no era nada el cantizal era
un cantizal precisamente una zona de
piedras de pedruscos de cantos etcétera
todo esto ha cambiado tantísimo como
cambio también ese embalse precisamente
con su fauna de entonces galápagos había
galápagos
el municipio vecino por eso se llama si
galapagar llegar a pagar tiene unos
galápagos en su escudo o justo podría
despistar cebreros tiene una cebra en su
escudo
es algo alucinante febrero es viene de
cabra no de cebra cebras ahí arriba pues
tiene una cebra en su escudo pero bueno
la gente que le eche una gran
imaginación a las cosas lo cual está muy
bien en términos literarios pero no en
términos toponímicos naturalmente bien
entonces decía que todos este tipo de
animales estaban ahí en molino y bueno y
por otra parte era un enclave donde
vivirían a lo mejor 300 personas 400 hoy
en día podemos multiplicarlo por 10
fácilmente es un pueblo es un pueblo
maravilloso pero seguimos con este
problema esencial que es el del embalse
y aquí quiero hacer en fin quiero
protestar quiero decir quiero pedir que
se haga eso necesita una limpieza
urgentísima eso lleva 50 años sin tonso
sin tocarse está como estaba cuando yo
llegué pero con el agravante de que
desde entonces ha pasado muchísima gente
esa presa de ahí abajo la rústica
digamos que no depura bien él no la
presa la persona tiene porqué depurar si
no no hay una depuradora incluso hace
años se había una idea disparatada que
era unir esto con molino salvando la
barranca que hay ahí abajo salvando el
río guadarrama promedio de un puente
como si viviéramos en aquellos tiempos
del cumple perdón ahora mismo y una
inquietud de ecológica y es fundamental
que esto no decaiga que esto no se venga
abajo yo también vengo un poco y un plan
vengo encantado muy agradecido a la
roberto espinoza a raquel a olivia que
es un amor a quien tengo como alumna de
poesía ahora voy a hacer un alegato a
favor del colegio logos que tiene un
taller de poesía que tiene clases de
poesía cosa que lo digo yo que explico
yo esa materia y perdonen que me ponga
tiempo orgulloso del tema pero después
de 46 años dando clase en logos me
siento muy feliz de reivindicar este y
de reivindicar a alumnas como libia y
profesores como marta buesa que está por
ahí encargada del tema y que me sustenta
tantísimo desde el punto de vista
poético
el tiempo se está acabando yo
normalmente mis conferencias y recitales
de poesías son muchísimo más amplios es
mucho más difícil fijaos a hablar diez
minutos o doce minutos de hablar siete
horas como hacía fidel castro- por
ejemplo puedes estar hablando si te
horas puedes estar divagando puedes
decir lo que te dé la gana puedes aquí
tienes que concentrarte esto tiene que
tener un valor epigramático epigramático
no como campoamor como quevedo y todos
aquellos que las hijas de las madres que
me tanto me besan hoy como quien besa un
santo
don ramón de campoamor pero por eso me
estoy conteniendo porque estoy viendo
ahí ese reloj que tiene israel que marca
un minuto con cinco segundos y tengo que
seguir concentrándome voy a volver a
citar a antonio machado y ruiz que acaba
ese poema maravilloso el del olmo
y entonces dice que mi corazón también
espera hacia la luz y hacia la vida otro
milagro de la primavera entonces aquella
tormenta que echó abajo el olmo tormenta
probablemente gemela de aquella que echó
abajo la presa del gas como nos va a
comentar
eulalia dentro de un momento entonces yo
quiero pedir como sea por favor que se
me escuche que se me atienda que corran
la voz que molino de la hoz es una de
las cosas más hermosas que hay en españa
es una organización súper privilegiada
pero hay este problema hay este problema
ese río hay que sanearlo ese río que no
va a dar a la mar que diría jorge
manrique sino que va a dar a la gran
cloaca cerca de toledo a 22 del tajo va
fino también señores y bueno pues quiero
agradecerles a te de esta oportunidad yo
venía un poco desganado mañana me voy
para galicia el calor me afecta mucho
sinceramente pero estoy muy contento de
estar con este público tan selecto y
además a cara descubierta ya mí es lo
que más me gusta muchísimas gracias a
todos de corazón